BRAVO LEO, AND BRAVO LLOYD.
>> AMAZING.
>> YEAH.
>>> MY "TALK OF THE TABLE" LOOKS
AT A PROVOCATIVE NEW VOICE IN
COMEDY WHO'S NOT AFRAID TO ASK
TOUGH QUESTIONS ABOUT RACE.
ZIWE BECAME A SOCIAL MEDIA
SENSATION LAST SUMMER AND IS NOW
THE HOST AND EXECUTIVE PRODUCER
OF HER OWN VARIETY SERIES
DEBUTING ON SHOWTIME, A DIVISION
OF VIACOMCBS.
"TIME" MAGAZINE CALLS HER THE
PANDEMIC'S MOST PROVOCATIVE
COMEDY STAR.
HERE'S A LOOK AT HOW SHE TACKLES
RACE RELATIONS AND OTHER SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES AS PART OF HER
COMEDY.
>> I'M YOUR HOST BRZIWE.
OUR GOAL IS TO END RACISM OR
YOUR MONEY BACK, AND THIS SHOW
IS FREE.
>> IN 2017 COMEDIAN ZIWE
LAUNCHED A YOUTUBE SERIES WITH
THE GOAL OF CREATING A DIALOGUE.
SHE USES HER SATIRICAL HUMOR AND
CONFRONTATIONAL QUESTIONS TO
HAVE AWKWARD, SOMETIMES
OUTRAGEOUS CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
RACE.
>> WOULD YOU NAME ANY
STEREOTYPES ASSOCIATED WITH
BLACK FOOD?
COULD YOU LIST THEM?
>> DO I HAVE TO?
>> LAST SPRING AFTER HER LIVE
COMEDY SHOWS WERE CANCELED DUE
TO COVID, ZIWE TOOK HER YOUTUBE
SHOW TO INSTAGRAM LIVE.
SHE SOON BECAME A SOCIAL MEDIA
SENSATION AS THOUSANDS TUNED IN
WEEKLY TO WATCH HER ASK
UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTIONS.
>> WOULD YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF
THE CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS OF FOOD
INFLUENCING?
HOW MANY REFERENCES DO YOU HAVE,
CAROLINE?
>> VERY MANY.
SO MANY.
>> VERY MANY?
>> YES.
AS DONALD TRUMP WOULD SAY, HUGE,
A HUGE AMOUNT OF BLACK FRIENDS.
>> I DO NOT APPROVE OF THIS
MESSAGE --
>> Reporter: NOW THE COMEDIAN IS
SET TO EXECUTIVE PRODUCE AND
STAR IN A NEW VARIETY SERIES FOR
SHOWTIME CALLED "ZIWE."
>> ARE YOU A RACIST?
>>MY FACE IS BLURRED FOR THIS?
>> HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU SAID
THE "N" WORD?
>> THE A OR THE ER?
>> THE SERIES WILL FEATURE
SKETCHES AND GUEST INTERVIEWS.
>> WHAT BOTHERS YOU MORE, SLOW
WALKERS OR RACISM?
>> THAT'S A REAL QUESTION?
>> YOU HAVE A BOOK CALLED
"PRETTY POWERFUL."
WHY DO YOU THINK UGLY PEOPLE
CAN'T BE POWERFUL?
>> AS WELL AS MUSICAL
PERFORMANCES FEATURING ZIWE
HERSELF.
♪
♪ STOP BEING POOR
STOP BEING POOR ♪
>> AND ZIWE JOINS US NOW.
WELCOME, THANKS FOR BEING WITH
US.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE NEW SHOW.
>> THANK YOU.
I'M SO EXCITED TO BE IN THIS
HALLOWED GROUNDS LIKE "CBS THIS
MORNING" IS MY FAVORITE SHOW.
>> HALLOWED GROUNDS --
>> YOU THEY HAVE TO EVERYBODY.
>> TO ALL THE MORNING SHOWS --
>> NO.
YOU GUYS DO FANTASTIC REPORTING.
>> THANK YOU.
HERE I WAS WORRIED YOU WERE
GOING TO ASK AN UNCOMFORTABLE
QUESTION.
>> WE'RE GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
>> LISTEN, ZIWE, START BY GIVING
US SOME SENSE OF HOW YOUR COMEDY
CAME ABOUT.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO USE
UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTIONS AS A
FORM OF COMEDY?
>> TOTALLY.
I MEAN, I'VE JUST LIVED FOREVER,
AND I'VE HAD ALL OF THESE
UNCOMFORTABLE CONVERSATIONS ALL
OF MY LIFE WHERE I'M LIKE
TALKING TO SOMEONE AND THEY'LL
BE LIKE, OKAY, I HAVE FOUR BLACK
FRIENDS, IT'S LIKE, SIR, THERE
IS A WENDY'S Y. DID YOU BRING
THAT UP?
AND I WONDERED WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF THERE WAS A CAMERA IN FRONT
OF -- IN FRONT OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
LIKE IF SOMEONE WOULD WATCH
THEM.
SO THIS IS MY VERSION OF LIKE
HEALING AND WORKING THROUGH ALL
OF THE TRAUMA I'VE EXPERIENCED
IN MY YOUNG ADULT LIFE.
>> YOU'VE ACTUALL SAID THAT --
I THINK YOU SAID TO SOMEONE THAT
YOU'RE PERPETUALLY AFRAID OF
OFFENDING PEOPLE.
YOU'RE WALKING A TIGHTROPE HERE,
AREN'T YOU?
>> TOTALLY.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT I HAVE SET
MYSELF UP FOR DISASTER IN THAT I
NEVER WANT TO PERPETRATE
DISCRIMINATION OR MARGINALIZE
PEOPLE.
I'M ONLY TRYING TO HAVE REALLY
FUNNY, LIGHTHEARTED
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
UNCOMFORTABLE AND REALLY GET AT
THE HEART, THE ISSUES WITH RACE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO YEAH, IT'S A TIGHTROPE, BUT I
HOPE THAT I'M DOING IT WELL.
>> YOU'RE DOING IT VERY WELL.
CAN I JUST SAY, I LOVE THAT
YOU'RE DOING IT, NUMBER ONE.
RACE MAKES SO MANY PEOPLE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
IF WE DON'T TALK ABOUT IT,
NOTHING CHANGES.
BUT YOUR UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTIONS
LIKE YOU'RE INTERVEWING A WHITE
WOMAN AND SAY, HOW MANY WHITE
WOMEN ARE IN NEW YORK, SHOULD
THEY GO BACK TO WHERE THEY CAME
FROM?
YOU'RE ASKING A WHITE WOMAN,
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF WHITE WOMEN
DO YOU HATE.
TWO, WHEN YOU GO TO A JOB
INTERVIEW YOU THINK LIKE A WHITE
GUY.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS HILARIOUS.
BUT YOU'RE SAYING RACE PERMEAES
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR LIVES.
AND WHAT WE REALLY HAVE TO DO IS
UNLEARN RACIAL BIASES.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
IT'S SO TRUE, BUT I WAN YOU TO
EXPLAIN IT.
>> SURE.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT UNLEARNING
RACIAL BIAS IS THAT WHETHER YOU
DISCUSS RACE CONSCIOUSLY OR
SUBCONSCIOUSLY, YOU'RE BRINGING
YOUR LEARNED BEHAVIORS, THE
THINGS YOU LEARNED IN SCHOOL,
INTO THE CONVERSATION.
I MEAN, THE WAY THE HIGHWAYS ARE
BUILT IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE
TO DO WITH RACE.
IT'S PART OF EVERY FACET OF OUR
SOCIETY.
AND SO I'M HOPING TO SORT OF --
I'M HOPING TO NORMALIZE THESE
CONVERSATIONS SO PEOPLE DON'T
FEEL LIKE IF I SAY THE WRONG
THING I'M GOING TO DIE, I'M
GOING TO GO TO JAIL, I'M GOING
TO GET CANCELED.
ULTIMATELY, WE CAN SAY THE WRONG
THING AND LEARN AND GROW AND
BECOME BETTER PEOPLE.
AND BUILD A STRONGER COMMUNITY.
>> WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT --
>> GLOBALLY HONESTLY.
>> WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT CANCEL
CULTURE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
PEOPLE DON'T TALK ABOUT THESE
ISSUES BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY THE WRONG
THING.
THEY MAY SAY THE WRONG THING IN
GOOD FAITH OR IN BAD FAITH.
EITHER WAY, THEY CAN END UP SHUT
DOWN.
BUT YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN THAT.
EXPLAIN WHY.
>> I MEAN, NOT EXACTLY -- WHAT
IS CANCEL CULTURE REALLY?
IT SEEMS LIKE A BAD PRESS DAY.
MAYBE A BAD DAY ON TWITTER.
BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S TWOFOLD.
ONE, CANCEL CULTURE REALLY
DOESN'T ENCOMPASS -- IT
ENCOMPASSES TOO MUCH.
ON ONE HAND, IF YOU ARE ARRESTED
FOR ASSAULTING YOUR EMPLOYEES
VERSUS IF YOU TWEET THAT YOU
MAYBE DON'T LIKE BEYONCE.
AND THAT IS TOO WIDE OF AN
UMBRELLA FOR SOCIETY.
>> BUT DO WE --
>> FURTHERMORE --
>> GO AHEAD, I'M SORRY.
GO AHEAD.
>> NO, PLEASE.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY DO WE NEED
AN INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT BOARD
LIKE FACEBOOK SET UP TO LIKE
HANDLE THESE CASES AND MAKE
JUDGMENTS?
AND THEY'D BE BINDING.
>> EXACTLY.
WE NEED ERIC HOLDER TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION AND REALLY GET AT
THE ROOT OF CANCEL CULTURE
BECAUSE IT'S TOO WIDE.
AND THEN THOSE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
CANCELED -- I MEAN, YOU LIVE IN
YOUR MANSION, YOU HAVE A NICE
LIFE, YOU GET A VACATION.
DOESN'T SEEM SO BAD.
>> YOU KNOW --
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
CANCEL CULTURE IS EXACTLY.
>> YOU GREW UP IN LAWRENCE,
MASS.
FOR A TIME YOU WERE PLANNING TO
BE A MATHEMATICIAN.
HOW DID YOU TAKE THIS TURN TO
COMEDY?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I HATED MATH
CLASS BECAUSE --
>> ME, TOO.
>> HATED MATH CLASS.
IT WAS UNPLEASANT.
I'VE ALWAYS HAD THIS
PERSONALITY.
SO I THOUGHT THAT PROFITING OFF
OF MY TRAUMA WAS THE BEST CASE
SCENARIO FOR ME.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I'M A
COMEDIAN.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S FUNNY,
THOUGH, ZIWE, IF A WHITE WOMAN
WAS SAYING WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
IF THE SAID WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT WHITE PEOPLE, IF A WHITE
WOMAN WAS DOING IT, I'D BE FEEL
SOMETHING KIND OF WAY ACTUALLY.
I'D BE, WELL, THAT'S NOT FUNNY.
BUT THE WAY YOU DO IT, THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT MAKES IT VERY
PALATABLE.
WHY IS IT OKAY, WHY IS IT OKAY?
AND YOU'VE SAID THAT YOU WANT TO
BE THE ELLEN DeGENERES OF RACE
RELATIONS.
I LIKE THAT.
TELL ME WHY IT'S OKAY AND WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN THE ELLEN
DeGENERES OF RACE RELATIONS
BECAUSE ELLEN IS VERY FUNNY AND
SMART.
>> ULTIMATELY MY GOAL IS TO LEAD
WITH KINDNESS.
BECAUSE I AM NOT THE JUDGE,
JURY, EXECUTIONER.
I CAN'T DICTATE WHAT IS RIGHT
AND WHAT IS WRONG.
ALL I CAN DO IS ASK IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS, AND THEN WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD AND BE VULNERABLE AND BE
HONEST.
WHEN YOU SEE THESE INTERVIEWS
WITH FRAN LIEBOVITZ OR GLORIA
STEINEM FOR EXAMPLE, OUR PILOT
EPISODE ON SUNDAY, YOU'LL SEE
PEOPLE BEING HONEST AND RAW AND
HAVING CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
NOT HAD ON TELEVISION AT ALL.
>> YOU'RE ON TO SOMETHING --
>> I THINK THAT VULNERABILITY IS
REALLY POWERFUL.
>> YOU'RE ON TO SOMETHING.
I KNOW YOUR PARENTS WERE HOPING
YOU'D BE A DOCTOR OR LAWYER.
I HOPE THEY'RE VERY PROUD OF
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
YOU'RE TERRIFIC.
>> MY PARENTS DON'T KNOW WHAT I
DO FOR A LIVING.
THEY KNOW THIS SHOW.
THEY WATCH IT.
SO THIS IS AWESOME.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ZIWE, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE SERIES "ZIWE" PREMIERES
SUND